das ist eine Geschichte über Kleidung
über die Kleidung die wir tragen über
die Menschen die Kleidung herstellen und
über die Auswirkungen die das alles auf
unseren Planeten
hat es ist eine Geschichte über Gier und
Angst macht und Armut es ist sehr
komplex weil es sich über die ganze Welt
erstreckt aber es ist auch ganz einfach
weil es unsere Verbindung zu den
Menschen aufzeigt die mit Herz und
Händen hinter dem ganzen
[Musik]
stehen ich trieb in diese Geschichte
hinein ohne einen Ahnung über Mode und
fing mit ein paar ganz einfachen Fragen
an was ich jedoch herausfand hat mein
Denken über die Kleidung die ich trage
für immer verändert und ich hoffe dass
es das gleiche bei dir
bewirkt am besten du beginnst mit deinem
Namen und erzählst wie alles
anfängt
ich heiße lucyel und ich bin
Journalistin und Moderatorin aus
Großbritannien und ich bin seit über 10
Jahren förmlich besessen von den
umweltpolitischen und sozialen
Auswirkungen der
Modeindustrie ich liebe Kleidung einfach
ich liebe alles an ihr die Poesie den
Stoff die Farben das Gewebe sie sind
unsere zweite
ha ich hatte natürlich auch den
klassischen riesigen Kleiderschrank und
beinah täglich stopfte ich ihn mit immer
neuen Taschen und Klamotten voll und
trotzdem hatte ich nie etwas zum
Anziehen nie konnte ich ein passendes
Outfit
zusammenstellen wir kommunizieren unsere
Identität teilweise über unsere Kleidung
das ist geschichtlich gesehen nichts
neues es gibt ja die Trends am Hofe und
Marie antoette mit ihren riesigen hüten
es war schon immer eine sehr persönliche
Kommunikation vielerlei Hinsicht und
genau das interessiert mich besonders
daran nämlich dass es ein fundamentaler
Teil davon ist was wir über uns zu
kommunizieren
Wünschen in der Mode entwickelte sich
eine Art modenschausystem mit den vier
Jahreszeiten wie in der Natur und lange
Zeit lief es auch erstaunlich präzise
wie ein Uhrwerk doch heute kann man das
getrost aus dem Fenster werfen denn es
hat überhaupt nichts mehr mit der
heutigen Modeindustrie zu tun
heute gelten völlig neue
Regeln der Fokus verschiebt sich auf
skrupellose Weise von der Erschaffung
hin in eine Richtung die eigentlich nur
noch großen Geschäftsinteressen
dient als Teenager machte ich mir
eigentlich nur Gedanken über den Preis
der Klamotten die ich kaufte entweder
traf ich meine Wahl nach Schnitt oder
gutem Angebot rückblickend bemerkte ich
aber dass lange Zeit die meiste Kleidung
hier in Amerika produziert worden war in
den 60ern stellten wir immer noch 95%
unserer Kleidung selbst her heute sind
es nur noch etwa 3% und die anderen 97%
werden in sämtliche Entwicklungsländer
[Musik]
ausgelagert ich bin seit 9 Jahren im
Modegeschäft wir haben über 25000
Beschäftigte alleine in der
bekleidungsartikelproduktion und wir
produzieren eins von sechs Hemden die in
den USA verkauft werden
wenn man in einen Laden geht und den
Richtpreis eines bekleidungsartikels mit
dem Preis von vor 20 Jahren vergleicht
wird man eine preisdeflation feststellen
das heißt der Preistrend ist
kontinuierlich gesunken doch sind auch
unsere Kosten gesunken ganz sicher nicht
im Gegenteil sie sind gestiegen je mehr
an Produktion outgesourc wurde desto
niedriger wurde der Preis unserer
Kleidung dabei entstand ein völlig neues
Modell namens fast fashion schnelle Mode
das praktisch über Nacht die Art und
Weise wie Kleidung gehandelt wurde
veränderte der neueste im Herzen von
Manhattan ist der bisher größte des
Unternehmens und gerade mal eine von
vielen Filialen die im ganzen Land
geplant sind das ist alles Teil einer
High Stre Revolution fast fashion
anstatt zwei Saisons im Jahr haben wir
jetzt praktisch 52 Saisons im Jahr das
heißt jede Woche sehen wir etwas Neues
reinkommen und fast Fashion hat das
geschaffen damit sie im Grunde nur mehr
verkaufen
[Musik]
können
diesen metallischen fransenrock gibt es
für 39 bei Joe fresh einem brandneuen
Laden in der Stad mit PR die
wahrscheinlich noch mehr preisbewus
Käufer ansprechen werden amerikanische
Kunden haben die Rolle von H und M in
der Mode wirklich verstanden und wir
wissen dass amerikanische Kunden sehr
wertorientiert sind wenn man diese
beiden zusammenbringt also Mode und Wert
dann hat man das
Erfolgsrezept dieser japanische
Textileinzelhändler verzeichnet in den
USA einen gewaltigen
Erfolg die Preise sind gefallen doch die
Herstellungsweise hat sich völlig
verändert und irgendwann fragt man sich
wo hört das alles
auf der globale Markt ist ein Ort an dem
wir Arbeit exportieren unter welchen
Bedingungen auch immer und anschließend
die Produkte zu mir zurückkommen und
zwar billig genug um sie bedenkenlos
wegwerfen zu
können globalisierte Produktion bedeutet
im Endeffekt dass die gesamte
Herstellung der Güter in
niedrigkostenländer ausgelagert wurde
besonders dahin wo sehr niedrig sind und
auch niedrig gehalten werden das
bedeutet dass diejenigen an der Spitze
der Wertschöpfungskette entscheiden
können wo die Produkte hergestellt
werden dabei können sie schön hin und
her wechseln wenn z.B eine Fabrik sagt
dass sie es nicht mehr so billig
produzieren können erwidert die Marke
tja dann beauftragen wir sie eben nicht
mehr und wechseln dahin wo wir es
billiger
kriegen
die Läden im Westen haben täglich
niedrig Preise das heißt jeden Tag werde
ich von denen gedrückt und ich muss
meine Arbeiter drücken so läuft das die
Läden stehen im ständigen
Konkurrenzkampf und wenn Sie zu uns
kommen wegen einer Bestellung oder einer
Verhandlung heißt es der Laden XY
verkauft dieses Hemd für 5 also muss ich
es für
anbieten ihr müsst es billiger
herstellen also machen wir das dann
kommt eine andere Marke und sagt hey die
verkaufen es für
dann ist unser neuer Richtpreis 3 wenn
ihr es auf 3 hinkriegt Geschft ansonsten
nicht weil wir die Aufträge so dringend
benötigen und keine andere Option haben
stimmen wir eben zu denn im Grunde
versuchen wir nicht mehr als zu
überleben so kann es nicht weitergehen
entweder steigt der Preis der Produkte
oder Hersteller müssen schließen bzw an
allen Ecken und Enden einsparen an allen
Ecken und Enden zu sparen und sogar
Sicherheitsvorschriften zu missachten
wurde in diesem neuen Geschäftsmodell
zur allgemein akzeptierten Norm bis
eines April morgens ein schrecklicher
Vorfall in Bangladesch die der
modeustrie auf die Titelseiten brachte
staatlichen Medienberichten zufolge
stürzte ein aöckiges Gebäude in der Nähe
von D ein bei mehr als 70 Menschen ums
Leben
[Applaus]
kamen Rettungskräfte stehen im Wettlauf
mit der Zeit in den tren sie verzweelt
nach
Überlebenden noch lebendig Behörden in
Bangladesch berichten dass die
fabrikinhaber eine Evakuierungsanordnung
ignorierten etwa 400 Tote hunderte
werden noch vermisst Fabrikarbeiter in
Bangladesch zahlen den hohen Preis
billiger
Kleidung eine riesige Menschenmenge hat
sich in der Nähe des Gebäudes versammelt
unter ihnen viele Familienmitglieder die
nach ihren Angehörigen suchen und sie
berichten dass sie noch immer
hilfeschreier aus den trn hören doch
viele verlieren langsam die
Hoffnung
ich ging von meinem Arbeitsplatz in
Richtung
Treppenhaus als ich es erreichte fiel
das Gebäude zusammen und meine Beine
wurden
eingeklemmt dann fiel noch die
Seitenwand auf meine
Beine mir wurde klar dass ich meine
Beine da nicht mehr rausbekam und gab
auf sich Gedanken rasten mir durch den
Kopf nicht mal weinen konnte
ich
[Musik]
jeder der wie ich über die Probleme in
der belieferungskette geschrieben hat
insbesondere bei fast fashion versuchte
vor allem klarzumachen von wem das
höchste Risiko tatsächlich getragen wird
nämlich von denen die am stärksten
gefährdet sind und am schlechtesten
bezahlt
werden man hat immer wieder versucht es
zu verdeutlichen aber ich hätte nie
gedacht dass die Darstellung von dem was
man zu vermitteln versucht so
katastrophal ist Plaza war für mich wie
eine regelrechte
Horrorgeschichte zi Wochen nach der
Katastrophe und einer
niederschmetternden Opferzahl von
derzeit 931 kann man vom schwersten
Unglück in der Modeindustrie aller
Zeiten
sprechen ich glaube dass eines der
zutiefst beeindruckenden Dinge des Rana
Plaza Unglücks die Nachricht darüber war
dass die Arbeiter die Missstände des
Gebäudes dem Management bereits gemeldet
hatten sie hatten längst darauf
hingewiesen dass das Fundament des
Mauerwerks unsicher war und wurden sie
gezwungen wieder
[Musik]
reinzugehen viele der Überlebenden
fragen wieso sie zur Arbeit gezwungen
wurden obwohl das Management bereits
sowohl über den maroten Zustand des
Gebäudes Bescheid wusste als auch über
die Bedenken der Arbeiter am Tag des
Einsturzes sehr viel Kleidung in
amerikanischen Geschäften wird in
Bangladesch von Arbeitern hergestellt
die im Schnitt 2 am Tag verdienen
letzten Monat stürzte eine Textilfabrik
ein und riss mehr als 1000 Menschen in
den Tod einige Monate zuvor tötete ein
Fabrikbrand mehr als 100 Menschen und
während die Leichen und Körper aus den
Trümmern geborgen wurden fing heute früh
eine weitere Fabrik in Bangladesch Feuer
und forderte acht
Todesopfer als sich die unglücksberichte
häuften wurde es zu einer unumstößlichen
Tatsache dass sich drei der vier
schlimmsten Tragödien der Modegeschichte
alle in einem Jahr ereignet hatten so
wie die Zahl der Todesopfer weiter
anstieg so stiegen auch die Profite
weiter an das Jahr nach dem Runner Plaza
Unglück war für die Bekleidungsindustrie
das profitabelste Jahr aller Zeiten die
globale modeustriech fast billionenll im
Bangladesch ist jetzt der zweitgrößte
textilexporteur nach China wie das im
Gegensatz zu einigen seiner Konkurrenten
bleibt die Produktion in Bangladesch
spotbillig und Gewerkschaften haben nur
begrenzten Einfluss das Land ist am
absoluten Ende der Wertschöpfungskette
angelangt diese 1000 armen Menschen
verloren ihr Leben weil niemand sich um
sie kümmerte oder ein feuchten Dreck
scherte sie wollen nur den billigsten
Preis und den besten Gewinn so sollte es
nicht sein jeder sollte die
Verantwortung für diese Kinder
tragen doch es ist wie es
ist es tut mir leid aber es ist nicht
nur der
Preisdruck es hat vielh mit der
Missachtung des Lebens anderer zu tun
das ist einfach nicht
richtig wir sind doch schließlich im 21
Jahrhundert in einer globalisierten wel
lassen das Leben anderer einfach so
links liegen wie kann das
sein wieso ist diese gigantische und
raffgierige Industrie die so viele
Gewinne für so wenige Menschen generiert
unfähig Millionen ihrer Arbeiter
ordnungsgemäß und angemessen zu
entlohnen warum ist sie nicht imstande
deren Sicherheit zu gewährleisten wir
sprechen hier von grundlegenden
Menschenrechten wieso ist sie nicht in
der Lage diese Dinge zu leisten während
sie solche schwindelerregenden Profite
erwirtschaftett
nichttigunktioniert das ist meine
Frage Luc Frage klingt offensichtlich
doch anstatt dass sie beantwortet wurde
traf ich überall auf Menschen die immer
zu versuchten die Preise zu
rechtfertigen und die wirtschaftlichen
Vorteile zu verteidigen diese
Niedriglohn ausbeuterbetriebe sogenannte
sweops sind nicht die schlechteste
Option die die Arbeiter heutzutage haben
sie sind Teil eines Prozesses der die
Lebensstandards und Löhne steigert und
im Laufe der Zeit auch zu besseren
arbeitskonditionenhrt
Entwicklungsfaktoren sind physisches
Kapital Technologie und Humankapital
also die Fertigkeiten der Arbeiter diese
sweops bringen den Arbeitern diese drei
Faktoren und setzen diesen Prozess
inang könnte es sein dass dieses
eigentlich gut sind ja genau
schreckliche ausbeuterbetriebe allein
dieser Begriff ruft furchtbare Bilder
von armen Menschen und leidenden Kindern
hervor die unter wiedrigsten Bedingungen
die Kleider für uns selbstsüchtigen
Amerikaner herstellen und vielen Dank
auch hierfür
beunruhigt es mich dass Menschen in
Fabriken arbeiten und Kleidung für
Amerikaner oder Europäer herstellen oder
dass sie auf diese Weise ihre Leben
verbringen ist es das wonach Sie mich
fragen ja
genau nein sie verrichten einfach nur
eine Arbeit es gibt weitaus schlimmere
Dinge die Sie tun
könntenür
sieier Arbeitsbedingungen die der
Durchschnittsamerikaner folgendermaßen
sieht niedrige Löhne gemäß unserem
Standard vielleicht auch
kinderarbeitsplätze die mit dem lokalen
Arbeitsrecht nicht konform sind aber es
gibt andere Kernelemente dieser Modelle
die ich gern ansprechen möchte nämlich
dass es auch Orte gibt an denen Menschen
sich aussuchen können zu arbeiten
zugegeben die Auswahl anderer Optionen
ist nicht gerade toll es gibt ja
eigentlich nichts wirklich gefährliches
an der Näharbeit an sich wir befinden
uns also in einer relativ ungefährlichen
Industrie nicht wie bei beim Bergbau
oder in der Erdgasförderung oder in
vielen anderen Bereichen die wesentlich
gefährlicher sind natürlich sehen Jobs
in den zops für jeden Westler der
wohlhabend genug ist Ihr Video
anzugucken erstmal nach furchtbaren
Arbeitsbedingungen und dampinglöhnen aus
aber wir müssen dabei auch bedenken dass
die vorhandenen Alternativen dieser
Arbeiter nicht unsere Alternativen sind
sie sind weitaus schlechter als unsere
und meistens sogar noch viel schlechter
als der fabrikjob den der Arbeiter hat
niedrige Löhne unsichere
Arbeitsbedingungen und Glücke werden
alle mit dem Argument entschuldigt dass
diese Jobs für Menschen ohne
Alternativen dringend benötigt werden
diese Geschichte wird immer wieder
aufgetischt sobald es darum geht das
globale Vorgehen der Modeindustrie zu
rechtfertigen aber es gibt auch
diejenigen die glauben dass es einen
besseren Weg geben muss mit Kleidung zu
handeln sie zu produzieren und mit ihr
Wirtschaftswachstum zu
erzielen wir wissen also noch nicht wie
lange diese Stickarbeit dauern wird
könntest du nicht Santo fragen wie lange
die ganze Stoffbahn grob brauchen könnte
wir wollen es ja später in der
Aufstellung sehen und da wäre es toll
das zu
wissen ich bin Safia mene Gründerin und
CEO von People Tree People Tree ist eine
Fair Trade Modemarke die vor über 20
Jahren in Japan ins Leben gerufen
wurde du hast dir Sorgen gemacht dass
wir vielleicht so viel marineblau haben
was denkst du jetzt wir haben in der
Sommersaison 14 viel schwarz verwendet
was mit oras Kooperation sehr gut
funktioniert haben wir genug
schwarzdrucke in der
Kollektion
wir haben den vorlagenabdruck in schwarz
verloren aber ich glaube dieser
rosafarbene Abdruck mit dem sich jeder
so schwer tut wird sich gut
verkaufen ich glaube dass die meisten
Modemarken mit einem kollektions oder
lookkonzept anfangen sie denken eher
nicht daran wer es am Ende herstellen
wird oder wie man sicherstellen kann
dass die Hersteller auch etwas zu essen
haben was wir bei people versuchen ist
zuerst die Fertigkeiten jeder einzelnen
Produktion Gruppe zu bündeln und dann
die Kollektion zu entwerfen ohne dabei
die Ganzheitlichkeit und Ästhetik der
Kollektion aus dem Auge zu
verlieren ich habe ursprünglich mit
freiberuflichen Designern gearbeitet und
ich bin oft nach Bangladesch Simbabwe
Indien Nepal und zu den Philippinen
gereist Stück für Stück haben wir uns
ein großartiges Netzwerk mit
gleichgesindtenade Organisationen
aufgebaut die die Entwicklung der Frauen
als auch der sozialen Umgebung der
Arbeiter als absolut notwendig
[Musik]
ansehen heute ist der 15 Jahrestag
dieser world Fair Trade Veranstaltung
wir organisieren diese Art von
Veranstaltung in über 60 Ländern und je
nach Land sind zwischen 10 und 60
verschiedene Organisationen mit an Bord
heute finden parallel wie wir es auch
hier machen Modeschauen und Seminare in
über 3000 Orten auf der ganzen
weltstattこるト 同 よ と
[Musik]
と世
könntest du dich etwas mehr zu mir
drehen das ist
wunderschönade ist die bürgerliche
Antwort auf soziale Ungerechtigkeit in
einem internationalen Handelssystem das
mehrheitlich völlig gestört ist bei dem
Arbeitern und Bauern kein
Existenzminimum gezahlt wird und die
Produktionsbedingungen der Güter die wir
täglich kaufen überhaupt nicht beachtet
werden
[Musik]
ich heiße Shima und ich bin 23 Jahre alt
ich war 12 als ich nach D
[Musik]
kam Arbeit auf der ganzen Welt fast 4
Millionen dieser Arbeiter leben hier in
Bangladesch und arbeiten in fast 5000
Fabriken in denen sie die Kleidung für
marktführende westliche Modelabels
herstellen über 85% dieser Arbeiter sind
Frauen und der Mindestlohn beträgt
weniger als 3 am Tag sie gehören zu den
am niedrigsten bezahlten textilarbeitern
der Welt ich wohnte zuerst mal bei
meiner Tante als ich zum ersten Mal in
einer Textilfabrik zu arbeiten begann
lag mein Lohn bei 10 im
Monat
[Musik]
meine Tochter die heißt Nadja
Akte an manchen Tagen nehme ich sie mit
in die Fab aber es istchtbar heiß dort
und überall gibt es Chemikalien die für
Kinder sehr schädlich
sind langfristig kann sie nicht bei mir
hier in D bleiben weil es niemanden gibt
der sich um sie
[Musik]
kümmert die Arbeiter dürfen keinerlei
Misstrauen in den Fabrikbesitzer haben
wennstra s kann keine gute
Arbeitsatmosphäre in der Fabrik
entstehen sie müssen also Respekt haben
weil der Besitzer sie gemäß der
Vereinbarung bezahlt wenn Sie diese Art
von Vertrauen nicht aufbringen erhält
man nicht das gewünschte
Resultat
আমাদের
থেকেন্টe eineerchaftegründet in der ich
seit aneg die Präsidentin
bin wir haben Liste mit Ansprüchen
eingere und die Manager haben sie auch
gelesen daraufolgend gab es heftige
Auseinandersetzungen
আমাদের Anschluss schlossen sie die Türen
und zusammen mit 30 oder 40 Angestellten
griffen uns die Manager an und schlugen
auf uns
ein sie nmen alles Stühle Stöcke
stoffwagen aber auch scheren um auf uns
einzuprügeln
sie schleuderten sogar unsere Köpfe
gegen die Wände und schlugen und traten
uns in Brust und
Unterleib es wird angenommen dass jeder
sechste auf der Welt in irgendeinem Teil
der globalen Modeindustrie tätig ist was
sie zur größten arbeitsabhängigen
Industrie der Welt
macht die meiste Arbeit wird von
Menschen wie Shima gemacht Menschen ohne
Stimme in der größten
Wertschöpfungskette der Geschichte aber
um die Auswirkungen zu verstehen die die
Modeindustrie auf uns hat müssen wir
dahin zurückkehren wo alles seinen
Anfang
nahm meine Großeltern siedelten sich in
den 20er Jahren hier an das ist also ein
Teil meiner Herkunft und die Leute
werden nicht müde zu fragen wieso ich bi
baumbollfarmerin bin mein Opa war ein
deutscher Landwirt der der festen
Ansicht war dass man das Land und das
Leben darauf respektieren
muss wir befinden uns hier in der
Hochebene von Texas und in dieser Region
wächstum auf einer Fläche von etwa 12000
qukm wir sind praktisch das größte
baumwollgebiet der Welt in nur 10 Jahren
wurden 80% davon zu genetisch
veränderter Baumwolle das meiste davon
ist Roundup Ready das heißt anstatt dass
die Landwirte oder saisonale Arbeiter
hier und da das Unkraut entfernen werden
die Felder nun vollständig
gespritzt Baumwolle produziert die Phase
die heutzutage in der meisten Kleidung
Verwendung findet und weil unser Appetit
auf Mode immer weiter anwächst wird die
Baumwollpflanze weiterentwickelt um
mithalten zu können es gab eine enorme
Kampagne für die Industrialisierung der
Landwirtschaft also zur Intensivierung
der
Landwirtschaft und diese trat an die
Stelle der alten Anbaumethoden die sehr
stark auf die Natur und die
jahreszeitlichen Zyklen abgestimmt
waren heute sehen wir eine
Intensivierung bei der das Land fast
gleichwertig wie eine Fabrik
behandelt schaffen die Millionen von
Landflächen einfach gleich behandelt wir
kippen einfach eine Ladung Chemikalien
drüber am Ende kriegen wir massive
ökologische Nebenwirkungen von denen
keiner eine Ahnung hat was da wirklich
passiert die Natur heilt sich
bekanntlich selbst aber nur in kleinen
Einheiten doch wenn wir mit dieser
riesengroßen Methode da anommen dann
können wir doch nicht wirklich wissen
was tatsächlich passieren
könnte wir sehen keine wirkliche
Reduzierung der Pestizide davon ist zwar
of die Rede aber doch nicht in unserer
Gegend in der aber Million Quadratmeter
der South Plains mit äußerst teurem
Roundup vollgesprüht werden welchen
Einfluss hat das auf unseren Boden der
durch die Rückstände in einem
mikrobiotisch desaströsen Zustand
hinterlassen wird welche Auswirkungen
hat das auf die Menschen in unseren
Gemeinden wo werden die Kosten dafür
abgebildet monento ist stolz darauf
industriürend landwitschaftlichen
Innovationen zu sein denn diese
Fortschritte können Ihnen dabei helfen
die Erträge für die zukünftigen
Bedürfnisse der Welt zu verdoppeln wir
geben uns der Zukunft der Landwirtschaft
hin und versorgen Landwirte mit
Innovationen die Ihnen helfen mehr zu
produzieren und mehr zu erhalten während
das Leben der Menschen auf der ganzen
Welt verbessert wird zusammen packen wir
die Herausforderungen der nächsten
Generation an und darüber
[Musik]
hinaus
nach den Kriegen standen überall diese
leeren Fabriken in denen die
kriegschemikalien und Sprengstoffe
produziert worden
waren die westlichen Länder meinten dass
es eine gute Idee sei sie an die Dritte
Welt zu vermarkten schließlich
produziert dieselbe Industrie die
Sprengstoffe herstellt auch
stickstoffdüngemittel also fingen sie in
den 1950er Jahren an nachdem wir
unabhängig geworden waren auf den Markt
zu
drängen doch die stickstoffdüngemittel
vertragen sich nicht gut mit den
heimischen Nutzpflanzen was an
lagerungsproblemen liegt daraufhin
reorganisierte sich das ganze System um
die Pflanze zu modifizieren damit sie
mehr Pestizide vertragen konnte BT
Baumwolle ist eine Baumwolle bei der ein
geh einer Bakterie hinzugefügt worden
ist um ein Gift zu produzieren aber die
BT Baumwolle die offenbar Schädlinge
abwehren kann wurde eigentlich nur
deswegen angeboten weil es ein Ungeheuer
einfacher Weg für die Konzerne ist das
satatgut zu besitzen durch die
Patentierung dieser genetisch
modifizierten Pflanzen konnte monsento
zu einem der größten Saatgut und
Chemiekonzern der Geschichte werden ich
wollte unbedingt mit jemandem sprechen
der bereits dort gearbeitet hatte und
ich erfuhr dass ein ehemaliger
Geschäftsführer für Indien dafür bereit
war ein guter Freund von mir der in der
Forschung war arbeitete an diesen
modifizierten Nutzpflanzen er kam zu mir
ins Hotel auf einen Drink und nach ein
paar Gläsern erzählte er mir dann hey
Jack die Art und Weise wie du Geschäfte
in Indien machst wird sich komplett
verändern ich fragte ihn was das bedeute
er sagte wir steigen in das
saatgutgeschäft ein und es heißt es soll
für alle Nutzpflanzen gelten so dass wir
ein Monopol auf Saatgut haben jeder
Bauer muss dann zu uns kommen und jedes
Mal neues Saatgut kaufen sofort
schrillten die Alarmglocken in mir auf
wenn ein armer Landwirt zu monsento
gehen muss um sein Saatgut zu kaufen und
zwar sehr teures Saatgut wie wird es
dann mit der BT Baumwolle damals wussten
wir noch gar nicht von genetisch
modifiziertem Saatgut ein Monopol auf
Saatgut ist etwas sehr schlechtes Bauern
müssen sich wegen der enormen Kosten von
über 17000% über ihrem Einkommen extrem
hoch verschulden um das Saatgut zu
beschaffen doch die angebliche sichere
pflanzenresistenz hält nicht was sie
verspricht sass sie mehr Pestizide
kaufen müssen die tragdie mit
Chemikalien gleich ob Dünger oder
Pestizid alle eine Art ökologisches
Rauschgift sind je mehr man sie einsetzt
desto mehr braucht man sie für eine
gewisse Zeit steigt der Gewinn des
Einzelnen Erzeugnisses doch dann sagt er
wieder ab weil der Boden verseucht
worden
ist der Großteil von Indiens Baumwolle
wächst in der ponjabreion die sehr
schnell zum größten Benutzer von
Pestiziden wurde dr pring hat die
Auswirkungen dieser Chemikalien auf die
menschliche Gesundheit untersucht und
seine Berichte weisen auf eine
dramatische Zahl an Geburtsfehlern Krebs
und Geisteskrankheiten in dieser Region
hin man kann in jedem Dorf herte
krebskranke Menschen sehen 70 bis 80
Kinder in jedem Dorf kämpfen mit
geistigen oder körperlichen
Behinderungen physical
handic
[Musik]
alle Unternehmen die Düngemittel und
Pestizide herstellen streiten diese
Nachwirkungen vehement ab und hier sehen
Sie ein typisches Symptom ihrer
Toxizität ein Dorf hat im Schnitt 60
geistig behinderte Kinder wie diesen
jungen hier es ist ein wirklich
gefährliches Phänomen im PAB Gebiet
dieen
Arbeiter Landwirte und Kleinbauern sind
hier schon längst am Limit angekommen
sass sie sich keine Behandlung mehr
leisten
können im Grunde haben sie sich schon
längst mit dem Tod ihrer Kinder
abgefunden und warten nur noch darauf
dass er kommt wie diese Mutter
hier die Unternehmen die das
genmanipulierte Saatgut herstellen sind
dieselben wie die die Chemikalien
herstellen aber auch die Medik die sie
jetztatentieren lassen WN man also Krebs
bekommt werden noch mehr Gewinne
generiert für die ist es eine
aufwärtsdrehende gewinnspirale für die
Menschen und die Natur eine
abwärtsdrehende verlustspirale eines
Tages kommen dann die Vertreter dieser
Unternehmen und sagen zu den Bauern du
schuldest mir Betrag X doch du hast
nicht gezahlt also gehört dein Land
jetzt mir an diesem Tag geht der Bauer
raus aufs Feld und trinkt eine dieser
Flaschen mit den Pestiziden jede Witwe
mit der ich sprach sagte mir dann kamen
die Nachbarn und sagten dass sie meinen
Mann im Feld liegen
sahen
in den letzten 16 Jahren gab es über
250.000 erfasste selbstmordfälle von
Landwirten in Indien das entspricht etwa
einem Farmer alle 30 Minuten und es ist
die größte erfasste Selbstmordrate in
der
[Musik]
Geschichte je klarer die Auswirkungen
der Modeindustrie für unsere Welt werden
desto stärker steigt die Zahl an
forschungsbeiträgen die aufzeigen dass
sie genauso Auswirkungen auf uns hat den
Konsumenten dieser
Kleidung heute also 20 Jahre und 100
Studien später wissen wir dass je mehr
Menschen ihren Schwerpunkt auf
materialistische Werte legen desto
wichtiger erscheinen für Sie Geld Image
Status und Besitz zu sein und desto
unglücklicher deprimierter und
verängstigter werden
sie wir wissen dass all diese
psychologischen Probleme mit dem Anstieg
materieller Werte ebenfalls mit
ansteigen allerdings steht das in
totalem Widerspruch mit den
abertausenden Werbebotschaften die jeden
Tag auf uns einwirken und uns sugerieren
wollen dass Materialismus und das
Streben nach Besitz uns glücklicher
machen es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass
Werbung eine Form bzw Strategie der
Propaganda ist wir sehen Propaganda als
etwas düsteres und totalitäres
Lautsprecher singende Menschenmassen und
so weit wir denken sofort an Hitler und
stellen es uns als etwas ausländisches
vorit
am ein
hur der Grund wieso Werbung funktioniert
ist dass die schlauen Werbefachleute
zumindest versuchen eine Botschaft
anzuhängen die UN sugeriert dass unsere
Bedürfnisse nur durch den Kauf dieses
Produktes befriedigt werden
Ken es will glauben machen dass du
wunderschön in diesem Teil aussiehst
doch wenn du es anehehstck oder nicht so
gut darin aus und dann tut es dir leid
es gekauft zu haben dann kaufst du eben
ein
[Musik]
anderes
man muss mal nur an die autoreklame
denken die einem vermittelt dass man es
mit diesem Auto zu was gebracht hat oder
sogar zu einer besseren Person wird weil
man jetzt diesen BMW oder
Audi oder die ganzen shampooerbungen in
denen die Person am Ende schönes
glänzendes Haar hat beliebt ist und von
ihrem Umfeld geschätzt wird die
fundamentale Botschaft ist immer
dieselbe deine Probleme im Leben werden
nur durch Konsum
gelöst is through consumption you guys
today I'm coming to you guys with a
clothing ha i went shoing a couple days
ago and lerally went insane and bought
so many things Spam i don't know lerally
blown up by you guys saying you guys
wanted a so here it is do so first off I
have some things that I got from H&M so
then I
went it wasn't even a question it was
just like fate I just had to get it like
if it could levitate towards me it would
levitated I got
thisirt bright yellow and it was
850 je but up thing I just love this I
just loved it loved it loved it it's a
greay kN sweater and it has pink hearts
all over it I lived i love tideye things
like tiye things are literally the bomb
down has a little y sign on the front of
it I just love these so much and it's
just this really pretty light blue
Sweater i don't even know if I'm going
to wear this now that I got it
[Musik]
ich versuche zu verstehen warum Menschen
nicht realisieren dass sie eigentlich
immer ärmer werden und ich frage mich
was ich verändert haben könnte im
Vergleich zu meiner Jugend die Mode ist
etwas dass sich drastisch verändert hat
ich konnte mir ein zwei oder auch mal
vier T-Shirts im Jahr leisten doch jetzt
kaufen meine Kinder für jede Party ein
neues T-Shirt
so verstand ich dass fast fashion etwas
völlig Neues ist falls es Ihnen nicht
aufgefallen ist der Preis ist in den
letzten Jahren gesunken was vom
zunehmenden Verschwinden der
Mittelklasse kommt doch die Dinge die
Menschen wirklich brauchen sind sehr
kostenintensiv sowie ein Haus ein
Studium oder eine
Lebensversicherung anderseit ist eine
artelle desostes ein il unseres Lebens
geworden ich kann mir ein oder zwei
T-Shirts pro Party kaufen sogar pro Tag
und das obwohl ich sehr arm bin und die
Dinge verloren habe die ich wirklich
brauche heutzutage kaufen wir über 80
Milliarden neuer Kleidungsstücke pro
Jahr das sind 400% mehr als wir uns noch
vor zwei Jahrzehnten kauften die Art und
Weise wie wir Kleidung konsumieren hat
sich so stark und so schnell verändert
dass einige Menschen einen Schritt
zurücktraten um zu versuchen den
Ursprung dieses neuen Modells und
Konsequenzen einer solchen noch nie
daageesenen konsumsteigerung zu
verstehen es gab mal einen Artikel im
seiner Zeit führenden werbemagazin
printers ink von einem renommierten
Werbetexter namens Ernest elmokins einem
sehr bedeutenden Mann in der Kunst des
werbetextens dieser Beitrag trug den
Titel Konsumismus und besagte dass es
zwei verschiedene Arten von Produkten
gibt die einen die man g braucht sowie
Waschmaschinen Autos und so weit Dinge
die man sich langfristig anschafft und
die anderen die man verbraucht Kaugummis
Zigaretten und andere kurzlebige
Konsumgüter er schrieb dass es beim
Konsumismus einzig darum gehe die
Menschen dazu zu bringen Gebrauchsgüter
wie Verbrauchsgüter zu
behandeln mit der innovativen
Verkaufspolitik dre zum Preis von einem
ist ein Anzug von Joseph ab Bank sogar
billiger als eine Küchenrolle und jetzt
gibt es sie sogar in diesen praktischen
Spendern mit vier Anzügen zum Preis
eines einfachen Abendessens habe ich
kein schlechtes Gewissen mehr sie
wegzuwererfen wenn ich fertig
bin man muss sich nur mal die
müllddeponien ansehen die Menge an
Textilien die weggeworfen werden ist in
den letzten 10 Jahren stetig angestiegen
und das wirft natürlich ein schlechtes
Licht auf die fast fashion
Industrie weiter wir unsere Spezies
degradieren und unsere letzten übrig
gebliebenen ursprünglichen Instinkte
praktisch wegwerfen desto entschlossener
sind wir immer mehr Wegwerfartikel zu
produzieren das macht einfach keinen
Sinn Kleidung sollte nicht und kann
nicht einfach als Wegwerfprodukt gesehen
werden ich glaube dass es nach jedem
großen industriellen Wandel ist mal sehr
lange dauert bis man den Treck einer
verschmutzenden Sache riechen und sehen
kann und ich denke dass jetzt wieder
eine Wende stattf
ein Nichten kann die fast fashionustrie
massive negative Auswirkungen auf die
Entwicklungsländer
hat der Durchschnittsamerikaner wirft
etwa 37 Kil an textilapfällen Weg pro
Jahr das bedeutet mehr als 11 Millionen
Tonnen an textilabfällen allein in den
USA das meiste davon ist nicht
biologisch abbaubar was bedeutet dass
sie für die nächsten 200 Jahre oder
länger auf den Deponien bleerden währ
sie
[Musik]
schadstofusen ben gutes damitun Kleidung
zu spenden die Reise allein eines
T-Shirts das an eine Hilfsorganisation
gespendet wird ist absurd und
widerwärtig P ist eine wahre Krankheit
in Haiti und nicht nur in Haiti sondern
in praktisch jedem Entwicklungsland kann
man sagen es ist einaltiges
Problem
einfleidung sten die Menschen kommen und
kaufen kistenweise die Kleidung und
wissen nicht mal was sie kaufen das ist
Kleidung die an Hilfsorganisation
gespendet worden ist und in den
secondhand Läden der Organisation nicht
verkauft wird sie wird verpackt und in
die Drittweltländer verschickt und das
meiste landet dann
hier nur 10% der Kleidung die wir
spenden wird in secondäden bei uns
verkauft und je schneller wir uns
umziehen desto mehr wird in
Entwicklungsländer wie Haiti ausrangiert
durch die steigende Menge der secondhand
Kleidung in Haiti ist die lokale
Textilindustrie praktisch
verschwunden einstmals gab es hier einen
stolzen schneidereizweig heute
produziert er überwiegend billig
T-Shirts für den Export nach
Amerika früher als man dort noch
gearbeitet hat hat man ständig neue
Leute gesehen sie hatten den Wunsch und
die Hoffnung das nähereihandwerk zu
lernen vielen wurde es beigebracht und
dadurch gewannen sie die Zuversicht mit
diesen Fähigkeiten einen guten Job zu
finden heutzutage wird einem zwar noch
gezeigt wie man näht aber die Chancen
davon leben zu können sind praktisch
hoffnungslos ich sage den Leuten ständig
dass es nicht gut ist Dinge zu kaufen
weil sie nur 10 Kosten heute wenn man in
eine Bar geht oder so kauft man sich
vorher ein Kleid für 10 weil es so
billig ist denkt man schon gar nicht
mehr darüber nach und wenn es nicht mehr
gefällt
und man macht dasselbe immer und immer
wieder während das Bewusstsein über den
Einfluss der Mode auf unsere Welt wächst
fangen industriefachleute an die
Auswirkungen eines auf fahrlässiger
Produktion und auf endlosem Konsum
basierenden Konzeptes zu
hinterfragen wir bei Patagonia hassen
den Begriff Verbraucher es muss ein
besseres Wort geben wirorzugen eher
Kunden undw Kunden den Einfluss ihres
Konsums erkannt haben nämlich dass sie
als Konsumenten auch Teil des Problems
sind wir sind sehr zuversichtlich dass
wir unsere Kunden dazu ermutigen sich
uns beim Hinterfragen des Konsums
anzuschließen denn ohne reale
Reduzierung des Konsums haben wir nicht
das Gefühl eine kollektive Lösung für
die anstehenden Probleme zu finden
nämlich dem fortschreitenden Rückgang
der Gesundheit unseres
Planeten die Modeindustrie muss ja
eigentlich nur anfangen ihre
Arbeitsweise zu überdenken und die
konventionellen Formen in Frage stellen
für mich als Modedesignerin ist dies das
aufregendste im Moment viel aufregender
als die Farben der Saison auszusuchen
oder Schnitte und Rocklängen festzulegen
ich finde es in meiner Branche viel
herausfordernder zu sagen ich werde es
diesmal auf eine umweltschonendere Art
versuchen
der Handel hat durch die Werbung der
Gesellschaft eingeredet dass
Glückseligkeit in Dingen liegt und das
wahre Glückseligkeit nur durch den
jährlichen saisonalen wöchentlichen
täglichen Erwerb von immer mehr Dingen
erreicht werden kann wir wollen unsere
Kunden dazu anregen genau über diese
Suggestionen nachzudenken um zu
verstehen woher sie kommen und durch
dieses Verständnis können wir alle
zusammen diesen Prozess
verändern
[Musik]
die Kunden müssen lernen dass sie
diejenigen sind die die Verantwortung
tragen ohne sie sind wir arbeitslos und
das ist äußerst wichtig man ist
überhaupt nicht verpflichtet daran zu
glauben wenn es einem nicht
gefällt ich liebe diese stickerbeit
chantou ja sie ist wirklich sehr schön
findest du nicht dass wir die Stickerei
auf beiden Seiten machen sollten ich
finde wir müssten sie auch hier
anbringen es sieht irgendwie geizig aus
wenn sie nur vorne ist machen wir es
doch auf beide Seiten das wird nicht
viel mehr kosten
oder swows ist ein Fair Trade Mode
Unternehmen aber auch eine Art
Entwicklungsgesellschaft sie hilft über
3000 Menschen in diesem
Dorf ich komme etwa alle vi Monate her
wir nennen das produktionstps und wir
arbeiten mit den erzeug zusammen um
herauszufinden was die Hindernisse sind
um ein großartiges Produkt herzustellen
und um es richtig zu vermarkten wir
betreiben zudem auch Hilfe zur
Selbsthilfe und schauen uns auch hier
die Hindernisse an um mehr
Sozialleistung zu fördern und um den
Umweltschutz in diesem Gebiet zu
verbessern für mich geht es hier um
Partnerschaft und um eine gemeinsame
Erarbeitung von kreativen Lösungen mit
dem ganzen Team Probleme zu erkennen und
einen Weg zu finden der für alle
funktioniert
ich möchte den besten Mitarbeiter und
eine weibliche Repräsentantin von
swallow im August oder im nächsten
Frühling zu mir nach London einladen ich
will dass ihr darüber nachdenkt wer
dafür am besten wäre denn ihr sollt
wissen wer eure Kunden sind verstehen
wie der Markt richtig funktioniert und
allen hier davon berichten wenn ihr
wieder zurück
seid
চ্
এবার বলার পরে
কিন্তু সবচেয়ে ভালো একটা সংবাদ
এখন আগামী বছরে আপনাদের ভিতর থেকে সবচেয়ে
ভালো সুনামের কাজ করেছে এরকম একজনকে
লন্ডনে
[Applaus]
নিয়ে wenn sie es erstrangig macht
sollte sie es vielleicht Dichter
ansetzen এটা করতে হবে এখানে কি সিঙ্গেল
নে
হ
সিঙ্ gehen wir mal hoch in den musterum
für SS 15 kann sie mit uns kommen und
uns das nächste zeigen was sie
macht
[Musik]
ich hoffte ins geheheim dass People Tree
nicht notwendig wäre und dass wir ein
anderes Handelssystem hätten dass die
Menschenrechte achtet und die Umwelt
respektiert aber je länger ich in der
Entwicklung involviert war und enger mit
gewissen Partnern zusammenarbeitete
desto mehr schreckliche Handelspraktiken
entdeckte ich die alles unterminieren
woran wir und die meisten Menschen
glauben und was wir
wertschätzen
People Tree entwickelte sich organisch
aus einer großartigen Gruppe heraus die
fest daran glaubt dass es einen anderen
Weg geben muss wie man arbeitet lebt
konsumiert und mit anderen Menschen auf
humanere Weise interagiert ich hätte nie
gedacht dass People Tree einmal in
tausenden Läden verkauft wird ich sehe
noch so viele Stellen die wir anpacken
müssen und ich denke dass es nicht nur
um das Schaffen von 7000 Arbeitsplätzen
bei peoplee geht sondern auch darum man
zu einer Veränderung der Industrie
beiträgt und zeigt dass unser
Geschäftsmodell
funktioniert als wir mit dem
biologischen Anbau begannen gab es
damals nur zwei oder drei biofarmer und
wir gründeten die Texas organic cotton
Marketing kooperative die Vereinbarung
war dass sie anbauen und ich verkaufe
ich fing an mit Senatoren wie Jacob
javidz über die Baumwollpflanzen zu
sprechen und alle sahen uns nur noch an
als wären wir völlig verrückt geworden
oft werden Konsumenten auf Biomilch
aufmerksam durch eine ausgebrochene
Allergie z.B aber Baumwolle und andere
Stoffe die man an die Haut lässt
alarmiert Sie interessanterweise nicht
und das obwohl die Haut das größte Organ
ist das wir haben bei Lebensmitteln ist
es einfacher beim Bioapfel nehme ich
keine Chemikalien und Pestizide auf
doch bei Kleidung wird diese Verbindung
nicht hergestellt darum muss man die
Dinge aus einer entfernteren Perspektive
betrachten es betrifft auch unsere Luft
unseren ganzen Planeten und uns Menschen
erst dann bekommt man das richtige
Bewusstsein auch wenn man erstmal denkt
dass man selbst nicht unmittelbar
eingreift durch den Kauf eines biohemdes
doch der Einfluss zeigt sich im großen
Gesamtbild und ganz besonders an den
Orten wo die Baumwolle angebaut
wird
wir als biofarmer warten auf den eisigen
Frost denn er entblättert die Pflanzen
und wenn wir dann ernten öffnen sich die
Reifen Kapseln die die Baumwolle
beinhalten der sogenannte
baumwolpflücker der hier dann drüber
fährt heißt so weil er mit einer Gabel
die Baumwolle tatsächlich
pfückt da hinten kann man diese Maschine
sehen wie sie schon das halbe Feld
eingesammelt
[Musik]
hat ich glaube eines der größten
Probleme des derzeitigen Modells Profit
im Mittelpunkt steht und es
berücksichtigt einfach nicht alle Kosten
wie z.B die Kosten von
Wasserverschmutzung die Kosten von
Arbeitskraft die Kosten für die Gitter
an den Fenstern wenn Menschen in einer
Fabrik sterben wenn ein Feuer ausbricht
die Kosten für Landwirte die keinen
Zugang zu Bildung und Krankenkassen
haben ohne das wissen wir nicht was der
wahre Preis eigentlich
ist großen Ganges dem heiligsten aller
Flüsse er ist äußerst wichtig für 800
Millionen Hindus und dient als
Lebensader für nordindiien doch dieser
Fluss wird immer stärker verschmutzt und
von den Lederfabriken in Kanpur völlig
zerstört durch die stark wachsende
Nachfrage nach billigem Leder wurde
Kanpur zur Hauptstadt des indischen
lederexorts
jeden Tag werden hier über 50 Millionen
Liter giftiges Abwasser aus lokalen
Gerbereien ausgeschieden schwere
Chemikalien die zur Lederverarbeitung
eingesetzt werden wie das chromtrioxid
gelangen in die lokale Landwirtschaft
und sogar ins Trinkwasser an Orten wie
Kanpur fernab der Sichtweite der Welt
können führende westliche Marken billige
Materialien beschaffen und sich aus
aller Verantwortung gegenüber der
ansteigenden Kosten für Gesundheit und
Umwelt entziehen
[Musik]
die Menschen in dieser Gegend sitzen in
der Falle wegen der
gbereiverschmutzung die ganze Umgebung
ist verschmutzt ebenso Grund und Boden
die einzige Trinkwasserquelle das
Grundwasser ist mit Chrom kontaminiert
landwirtschaftliche Erzeugnisse wie
Salat und Gemüse werden dort angebaut
die gesheit
chtig und es gibt viele verschiedene
Hautprobleme wie Ausschläge Geschwüre
Pusteln sogar Taubheitsgefühle in den
Gliedmaßen sie leiden an
Magenerkrankungen möglicherweise auch an
Krebs meine Tochter leidet an Gelbsucht
fast in jedem zweiten Haus leidet
irgendjemand an irgendetwas und das wird
von Jahr zu Jahr immer
mehr unsere Ersparnisse fließen in die
Behandlung dieser Krankheiten weil
dieses aggressive Chrom in unserem
Wasser die Leber direkt
angreift es verursacht
Verdauungsprobleme und viele kriegen
davon Gelbsucht oder sogar Leberkrebs
weil sie nicht im standande sind
angemessene Vorkehrungen zu
treffen
man kann die besten Materialien in den
Luxusläden in Mailand Paris oder London
finden aber es steckt so viel
unsichtbare Arbeit drin so viele
Chemikalien wurden über Abwässer in die
Flüsse abgeleitet aber wir sehen zu
diesem Zeitpunkt nur das fertige
Produkt wir müssen einen Gang
runterschalten und darüber
nachdenken die Modebranche ist heute die
am zweitärksten verschmutzende Industrie
der Welt gleich hinter der Ölindustrie
das alarmierende ist nicht nur dass Mode
einen gewaltigen Anteil an Ressourcen
aufbraucht und gigantische Auswirkungen
auf die Umwelt hervorruft sondern auch
dass diese Ressourcen und Auswirkungen
meist gar nicht bemessen
werden weil diese Ressourcen so
reichlich vorhanden waren nahmen wir an
dass sie auf ewig ausreichen würden
darum hat der Handel sie nie in die
Gleichung mit einbezogen wir erleben ja
erst seit den 1950er Jahren diese
ausehnung in einem Maße inem wir
exponentielles Wachstum und
exponentielle Verwendung von Ressourcen
sehen das erste Wirtschaftssystem auf
dem unser Leben basiert ist die
naturwirtschaft diese Wirtschaft ist
zwar riesig wird aber nicht gezählt dann
haben wir die Wirtschaft der Menschen
der arbeitenden Männer und Frauen der
Bauern doch das alles wurde durch dieses
Konstrukt unsichtbar gemacht zuerst in
der Großen Depression und dann während
der
Kriegsjahre
die Zahl die als brutto Inlandsprodukt
bezeichnet wird misst nur das womit
gehandelt wird und das wurde zum neuen
ruhstoff viele Ressourcen die wir für
unsere Kleidung verwenden werden gar
nicht in die Produktionskosten mit
einberechnet also die Kosten für das
Wasser die Landflächen zum Anbau der
Fasern die Chemikalien zum
färben
all diese Dinge sind Eingaben und als
Eingaben kosten sie natürlich etwas aber
sie geben auch etwas
aus in manchen Fällen haben sie gute
Ausgaben wie die Kleidung selbst oder
Arbeitsplätze doch in anderen Fällen
geben sie sehr schlechte Dinge aus wie
schädliche Chemikalien oder
Treibhausgase aber auch diese Dinge
haben ihre
Kosten
leg dich auf das
Kissen wirst du traurig sein wenn du
Nadia wieder verlassen musst natürlich
werde ich traurig sein aber was soll ich
denn anderes machen mit meinem Job hier
bin ich gezwungen sie im Dorf
unterzubringen sie hat in den letzten
zwei Monaten fast nichts für die Schule
gelernt sie sieht nur fern Trickfilme
oder Musikvideos aber wenn sie im Dorf
ist geht das nicht mehr denn dann geht
sie morgens in die Schule und kommt zum
Mittagessen wieder heim und um geht sie
dann zum Privatunterricht das wäre hier
unmöglich und was machst du jetzt mit
Nadia na ja manchmal lasse ich sie bei
den Nachbarn manchmal kümmert sich ihr
Vater um sie und manchmal nehme ich sie
mit in die Fabrik so wie
gestern dieselben Niedriglöhne die
Bangladesch zu einem attraktiven
Geschäftszentrum für Marken gemacht
haben ließen Millionen Arbeiter
Überstunden ableisten sass es für viele
unmöglich wurde ihre Kinder bei sich zu
behalten sogar in den schlimmsten
Slums um ihren Kindern eine Ausbildung
und die Chance auf eine bessere Zukunft
als in den Fabriken zu ermöglichen
lassen viele Fabrikarbeiterinnen wie
Shima ihre Kinder bei der Familie oder
bei Freunden in den Dörfern in der
Hoffnung sie ein bis zweimal im Jahr
sehen zu
können
das ist mein Vater ich habe ihn vor
einem Jahr zuletzt gesehen manchmal
telefonieren wir aber gesehen haben wir
uns vor einem
Jahr und das ist meine
Mutter und auch wir haben uns zuletzt
vor einem Jahr gesehen wir telefonieren
ab und zu aber sehen uns nur
selten আজান যায় না এই কর গ্লাসে পানি যে
কয়জন রোজা আা এই কয়জন ফ্রিজে দে এগুলা
উঠায় দাও ফ্রিজে দিমু হ ফ্রিজেই দাও আর
চার চামচ দিয়ে দাও যে কয়জন রোজা আপনারাা
আর ওই যে দুইজন বড় রোজা আছে তাদেরও
দিবেন না
পাখিট সুোজা পাখিট সুজা আমি তো দেই নাি
কি সা হ্যা কোন জাগা এদিকে
আমাদের
বাংলাদেশ in Bangladesch sind grenzenlos
jeden Tag wen wir früh morgens auf gehen
in die Fabrik und arbeiten den ganzen
Tag wirklich schwer und mit all unserer
harten Arbeit stellen wir die Kleidung
her Kleidung die die Menschen auf der
ganzen Welt tragen doch diese Menschen
wissen of nicht
wie her sie
und
ich finde dass diese Kleidung auch mit
unserem Blut produziert wird denn
bereits viele Fabrikarbeiter starben bei
schweren Unfällen so wiee letztes Jahr
der fabrikeinsturz von Rana
Plaza viele Menschen sind dort ums Leben
gekommen es ist sehr schmerzhaft für uns
und ich will nicht dass jemand etwas
trägt das mit unserem Blut hergestellt
worden
ist wir möchten bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen für und dass jeder
darauf aufmerksam
wird ich will keine weiteren Inhaber wie
den von Rana PL der so viel riskiert hat
und die Arbeiter unter solchen
Bedingungen zuur Arbeit gezwungen
hat ich will dass niemand mehr so
sterben muss dass keine Mütter mehr ihre
Kinder auf diese Weise verlieren
müssen ich will dass die Inhaber mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen und mehr auf
uns
achten
eigentlich nutzen wir ihr Bedürfnis nach
Arbeit aus um sie als Sklaven zu halten
ich sage nicht dass wir das lassen
sollten nein wir müssen ihnen Arbeit
geben aber sie müssen mit demselben
Respekt behandelt werden mit dem wir
unsere Kinder und Freunde behandeln sie
sind nicht anders als
Wirt eine drastische Veränderung in der
Modeindustrie sie machte Schlagzeilen
mit der greenpet Challenge sie Stars und
Topdesigner dazu aufforderte Teil einer
aufmerksameren modegestaltung zu werden
sie betreibt ein Beratungsunternehmen
für Nachhaltigkeit namens Eco AG und
wurde auf eine Konferenz geladen um über
die Zukunft der Mode zu
sprechen wenn es fast fashion nicht gäbe
bräuchten wir kein Treffen in Kopenhagen
um zu versuchen die Zerstörung der
Umwelt und der sozialen Gerechtigkeit
die in den letzten 20 Jahren verursacht
worden ist zu
beheben fast fashion möchte schnell
produzieren also müssen die
Fabrikarbeiter schneller und billiger
produzieren daher sind die
Fabrikarbeiter das einzige Glied in der
Wertschöpfungskette bei denen die Spanne
gedrückt wird wir haben diese riesigen
Unternehmen die in den Fabriken von
Bangladesch Auftragsvolumina von 1,5
Millionen Jeans erteilen jeweils für 30
Cent oder 50 Cent wie kann man so etwas
ethisch rechtfertigen ich weiß es
nicht aber ist es auch aus Sicht der
Verbraucher wirklich demokratisch ein
T-Shirt für 5 zu kaufen oder eine Jeans
für 20 oder ziehen die uns über den
Tisch sie lassen uns glauben dass wir
reich und wohlhabend sind weil wir uns
viel kaufen können aber in Wirklichkeit
machen sie uns nur ärmer und die
einzigen die reicher werden sind die
Inhaber dieser fast fashion Marken das
macht mich etwas
ärgerlich
sie haben über die Verpflichtung des
Versuchs und des Versprechens eines
Grundeinkommens
gesprochen was bedeutet das wie
definiert man überhaupt ein faires
Existenzminimum in Bangladesch was heißt
das genau ein Pilotversuch in drei
Fabriken zu haben mit dem Ergebnis dass
15% eurer Fabriken so etwas bis 2018
umsetzen sollen das ist nicht
ausreichend bei weitem
nichts sollte die Definition eines
Existenzminimums von den Arbeitern
kommen und das sollte in unsere
Arbeitsweise integriert werden und wie
hoch sollte es sein unds steht es nicht
zu eine Höhe zu beziffern aber wir
machen regelmäßig
Schätzung die Grundbedürfnisse der
Arbeiter
deckt ich kann es ihn später gerne
zeigen H& m hat das Modell der fast
fashion perfektioniert und ist heute der
zweitgrößte bekleidungskonzern der
Geschichte mit einem jährlichen Umsatz
fast 18 Milliarden USDollar sie sind
einer der größten Bekleidungshersteller
sowohl in Bangladesch als auch in
kambodchja leider haben sie wie auch
alle anderen großen Händler die ich
gefragt habe alle Interviewfragen für
diesen Film
[Applaus]
abgelehnt in kambod hatten die
Fabrikarbeiter irgendwann genug und sind
vor kurzem auf die Straße um für eine
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns zu
streiken doch als die Proteste weiter
anhielten wurden die Arbeiter und
Arbeiterinnen auf brutale Weise
zurückgedrängt und die Polizei eröffnete
sogar das Feuer auf sie mit scharfer
[Musik]
Munition
eine Frau kam bei den Zusammenstößen
zwischen textilfabrikarbeitern und der
Polizei in kaboda ums Leben viele wurden
[Musik]
verletzt
zwei Tage lang war Kambodscha ein
einziges
Schlachtfeld vor allem die Hauptstadt
pnompen Polizei und Fallschirmjäger
rückten an als ob es einen Bürgerkrieg
gäbe und warum weil die Arbeiter der
Textilindustrie auf einen Mindestlohn
von 160$
behen
die Regierung ging mit aller herte gegen
uns vor und dabei wurden fünf Arbeiter
getötet 23 verhaftet und über 40
verletzt dabei verlangen wir doch
überhaupt nicht viel Geld wir möchten
doch auch nur einen angemessenen Lohn um
ein anständiges und würdevolles Leben zu
führen doch der Regierung ist es egal
wie arm wir sind oder wie sehr wir schon
gelitten haben die Arbeiter sind denen
völlig egal und daher verlangen wir
weiterhin einen Mindestlohn von 160 im
Monat
he ist Begräbnis eines fabrikarbeiters
der zu Tode geprügelt worden ist er
hatte vor seinem Tod heute Morgen sehr
schwer
gelitten dabei hat er nichts Falsches
getan er und seine Arbeitskollegen
wollten nur bessere
Lebensbedingungen
[Musik]
ยตา
สาปตัง
สมาิยตยั ส
ก
[Musik]
ส amp weiterführen so dass alle
kambodschanischen Arbeiter irgendwann
angemessene Arbeitsbedingungen bekommen
werden
[Musik]
danke die kambodsanische Regierung sowie
die anderen Entwicklungsländer Trachten
verzweifelt nach den Geschäften mit den
multinationalen Konzern wegen der stigen
bedoh diesen Produktionen in andere
Länder verlagern könnten drückt die
Regierung einerseits die Löhne und
übergeht andererseits regelmäßig das
Arbeitsrecht aber weil die großmarken
ihre Arbeiter nicht offiziell einstellen
bzw die Fabriken nicht deren Eigentum
sind sind Sie in der Lage gigantische
Profite einzufahren und gleichzeitig
keinerlei Verantwortung für die
Armutslöhne fabrikunglücke und
permanente gewaltsame Behandlung der
Arbeiter zu
übernehmen das ganze System fühlt sich
langsam an wie ein perfekt konstruierter
Albtraum in dem die Arbeiter gefangen
sind
man kann uns nicht täuschen uns unsere
Arbeitskraft berauben und auch noch
unsere Arbeiter Ausbeuten sie werden
ihren Kampf
weiterführen ich rufe die
internationalen Marken dazu auf unseren
täglichen Kampf in Dollars in Pfund in
Euros
aufzuwiegen es rechnet sich unmittelbar
um in menschliches Kapital und soziale
Verantwort
grkonzerne und es verwandelt sich in
wirtschaftliche
Gerechtigkeit wenn sich alles nur noch
auf die profitgenerierung für die
Konzerne konzentriert sieht man wie die
Menschenrechte Umwelt und Arbeitsrechte
allesamt verloren gehen man sieht dass
die Arbeiter immer stärker ausgebeutet
werden weil die Preise ständig
runtergedrückt werden und das alles nur
um diesem Impuls nach mehr
kapitalanhäufung zu befriedigen das ist
zutiefst problematisch weil es
Verelendung von hunderten Millionen
Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
führt wenn man solche Firmen anschreibt
schicken sie dir ihren Verhaltenskodex
zu und er ist immer wunderschön
formuliert mit Dingen wie wir übernehmen
Verantwortung für die Bedingungen unter
denen unsere Produkte hergestellt werden
wir erwarten von allen Fabriken die wir
beauftragen dass sie die
mindestlohngesetze einhalten die
Landesgesetze einhalten die Frauen
respektieren keine Kinder einstellen
keine Zwangsarbeit einsetzen keine
exzessiven Überstunden und so
weiter doch als wir dem Kongress vor ein
paar Jahren einen Gesetzesentwurf
vorlegten den wir Gesetz für angemessene
Arbeitskonditionen und fairen Wettbewerb
nannten antworteten alle Konzerne
einstimmig um Gottes Willen das wäre ja
ein himnis für den freien Handel wir
dürfen keine Regulierungen haben das
geht doch
nicht sie möten es igen Verhaltensnormen
belassen ich meine sie haben auch darum
gekämpft und rechte gewonnen die ihre
Dinge und Interessen konkret schützen
aber was ist mit den Arbeitern die
bleiben auf freiwilligen
verhaltensgrundsätzen sitzen und was wir
in immer mehr Fällen beobachten ist dass
diese freiwilligen Grundsätze nicht
einmal das Papierwert sind auf dem sie
stehen wir müssen besonders in der
Modeindustrie anerkennen dass
Humankapital ein erheblicher Teil dieser
wundersamen Formel ist ohne das
Humankapital ohne billige besonders
weibliche Arbeitskraft würde es solche
Profite gar nicht erst geben das muss
endlich anerkannt werden und es muss
eine Auseinandersetzung stattfinden dass
diese Menschen entlohnt und nicht
ausgebeutet werden was ist deren Anteil
das sollte eine ständige zentrale Frage
sein sind diese Käufer unmoralisch oder
sind sie einfach nur
amoralisch das System für dass sie
arbeiten und das System das Firmen so
etwas erlaubt ist amoralisch die
betroffenen Individuen sind einfach nur
ein Produkt dieses Systems was wir tun
müssen ist das Verhalten dieser Firmen
zu
ändern in einem System das nur Gewinne
bemissst haben Firmen wenig Anreiz etwas
anderes zu tun als den Umsatz im
nächsten Quartal zu steigern ganz gleich
welche Schäden dabei verursacht
werden sowohl Konzerne aus der Textil
als auch aus der Chemieindustrie und der
Landwirtschaft wachsen heutzutage zu
noch nie da gewesenen Größen und
machtordnungen heran diese oberste
Direktive der Gewinnmaximierung um jeden
Preis steht im direkten Gegensatz zu
unseren
Werten Richard Wolf ein Ökonom der seine
Abschlüsse in Harvard Stanford und Yale
absolviert hat ist davon überzeugt dass
das wahre Problem im System selbst
liegt Amerika ist zu einem äußerst
befremdenden Land geworden man darf das
Bildungssystem kritisieren um die
Schulen zu verbessern oder das
Transportsystem um die Infrastrukturen
zu verbessern aber das Wirtschaftssystem
darf man nicht kritisieren es hat quasi
einen Freischein darf es einfach nicht
und wenn man etwas seit 50 Jahren nicht
mehr hinterfragt fängt es an zu
schimmeln eine gesunde Gesellschaft kann
nur dann richtig funktionieren wenn sich
alle Systemkomponenten der Kritik
unterziehen lassen damit wir sie
diskutieren können um sie wieder zu
richten oder zu verbessern der
Kapitalismus aber durfte nicht
hinterfragt
werden der Kapitalismus ist der Grund
wieso die Modeindustrie heute so ist
darum haben Arbeiter in Bangladesch ein
so Nied Lohn den wenn man in einemchen
arbeitet ist das wichtigste Gewinne zu
machen und zwar immer mehr als die
Konkurrenz das SPT die Konzerne an die
Löhne noch weiter zu
drücken und die ganzen Modemarken gehen
nur aus einem einzigen Grund an Orte wie
Bangladesch nämlich immer nur um die
billigste Arbeitskraft zu bekommen
Bangladesch hat keine festen Tarife
keine Gewerkschaften einen extrem
niedrigen Mindestlohn kein mutterchutz
keine
Rentenkassen darum sitzt die
Modeindustrie in Bangladesch weil es die
größten Profite aus diesen Menschen
herausholen
kann bevor man ein Problem lösen kann
muss man erst eingestehen dass es eines
gibt und bevor wir ein Wirtschaftssystem
reparieren können das auf diese Weise
agiert und solche Spannungen
Ungleichheiten und Aufregung in unserer
Gesellschaft produziert müssen wir das
wahre Ausmaß des Problems erst einmal
erkennen und das ist das System als
Ganzes erst dann sollte ein nationale
Debatte gestartet werden in der wir
lange und tiefgründig über besser
funktionierende alternativsysteme
nachdenken die größte Bedrohung für die
Umwelt ist dass das Kapital unendlich
expandieren muss um zu überleben es darf
keine Grenzen in ausbereitung und
Wachstum haben die natürliche Welt hat
logischerweise Grenzen die ganz klar
definieren wie viel der Planet ertragen
kann bezüglich Produktion Handel
Transport und Distribution es ist
ziemlich offensichtlich viele dieser
Grenzen bereits überschritten haben
deswegen wir im Moment solchen Stress in
der natürlichen Welt
erleben das System in dem wir leben
entspricht überhaupt nicht den
Vorstellungen der meisten Menschen ich
denke es macht die meisten Menschen sehr
unglücklich und ich denke nicht dass
Menschen auf einem langsam dahinsieenden
Planeten leben oder von ihren Nachbarn
ausgebeutet werden wollen ich glaube wir
brauchen einen gewaltigen systemischen
Wandel wenn man das System nicht
verändert hält man die
Entscheidungsgewalt dieser Konzerne
intakt bedeutet dass eine kleine Gruppe
von Führungskräften und Aktionären
weiterhin im selben System arbeiten
werden das abhängig ist von denselben
Formen von Zuckerbrot und Peitsche und
sie früher oder später dazu bringen wird
irgendwo dieselben Bedingungen wiederz
schaffen gegen die wir jetzt anzukämpfen
versuchen man muss aufhören zu versuchen
die Bedingungen zu verbessern und
anfangen etwas am System zu unternehmen
sonst meint man es nicht
ernst unser Wirtschaftssystem ist der
Konsumkapitalismus desweg brauch die
Regierung einen sehr hohen Konsumismus
natürlich machen die Konzerne damit und
deswegen fangen die Menschen irgendwann
auch damit an die meisten mit denen ich
darüber gesprochen habe entgegnen mir
dann aber wenn wir den Materialismus
zurückschrauben wird die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen nun das stimmt natürlich
bis zu einem gewissen Grad weil unsere
Wirtschaft auf materialistischen Werten
fundiert das ist Teil ihres Antriebs um
zu überleben das Problem ist nur
wirklich her Preis dafür gezahlt
wird der Friday einkaufsw findet mal
wieder heute Abend in den amerikanischen
Kaufhäusern statt mancher Orts erscheint
es als ob jemand bekannt gegeben hätte
dass die Bestände für immer ausgehen
könnten und man besser alles stehen und
liegen
lassenoll Stunden ein neuer kundenrekord
15000 Menschen im New Yorker ma der
schwarze Freitag ist der stärkste Tag im
ganzen Jahr für den Einzelhandel und
hier bei ma machen wir so viel Umsatz an
diesem Tag wie an keinem anderen im
Jahr diese weihnachtsbummelg beweist
dass Amerika wieder zurück ist wir sind
wieder vereint oh
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jaer g die nichtuch sie Menschen Zuken
die wir nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mögen
things Gold RS Gold RS I
get i
want give what
[Musik]
I
[Applaus]
[Musik]
সুন্দর সুন্দর
ছবি আজকে পাপা দিয়ে
[Musik]
sie lieben die Kleinen sehr und sie
können besser auf sie aufpassen als ich
es kann aber eins macht mich doch
traurig unabhängig davon wie sehr es
geliebt wird kann keiner ein Kind so
sehr lieben wie die eigenen Eltern ich
bin
[Musik]
tounglücklich ich will nicht dass meine
Tochter so wie ich in einer Textilfabrik
arbeiten muss ich mache mir Sorgen aber
eines Tages werde ich wieder glücklicher
sein wenn ich weiß dass sie eine bessere
Zukunft
hat
sie wird ein guter Mensch und die Leute
werden sagen dass ihre Mutter ihr eine
gute Ausbildung und Erziehung ermöglicht
hat und das obwohl sie in einer
Textilfabrik in D arbeitete weit weg von
ihrer
Tochter wenn sie Beamtin wird oder einen
guten Mann heiratet werden die Menschen
wissen dass ich sehr stolz bin und dass
ich darum gekämpft und mein Bestes
versucht habe damit sie nicht dasselbe
durchstehen musste wie ich dass ich sie
gut erzogen
habe
[Musik]
ich wuchs auf einer Farm auf habe einen
Mann geheiratet der auch auf einer Farm
aufgewachsen war und wir lebten auf
einer Farm natürlich legten wir viel
Wert auf Sicherheit doch diese
neuartigen Chemikalien und die
Intensität in der sie angewendet wurden
stiegen stetig an dann im Jahr 2005 fing
Terry an einige feinmotorische
Fähigkeiten zu ver
astom mform hat einen Hirntumor vier
grades in der Blütezeit seines Lebens
mit
47 er starb schließlich mit 50 obwohl
die Ärzte ihm nur noch 6 Monate gegeben
hatten hat riesige krebskliniken und
medizinische Zentren darum mussten wir
für die Operation zum Glück nicht woers
hin wir Konten
deswegenleben Chur so viele dieser
Tumore behandelte er sagte uns dass
diese Art überwiegend bei Männern im
Alter zwischen 45 und 65 Auftritt die in
der Landwirtschaft oder in der
Ölindustrie tätig sind leider habe ich
keinen eindeutigen Beweis oder einen
Bluttest der aufzeigt dass die Nutzung
von Baumwoll und Agrarchemikalien
unmittelbar zum Tod meines Mannes
geführt hat obwohl es auch viele
ähnliche Verknüpfungen mit dem Tod
seines Vaters gibt wir wuchsen auf
chemieintensiven Farmen auf und lebten
in von 3,6 Millionen Quadrat Acker die
viele Pestizide benötigten zu diesem
Zeitpunkt wurde Bioanbau nicht mehr nur
wichtig für mich sondern zwingend
notwendig es ist auch zwingend notwendig
dass wir die Landwirtschaft verändern
und dass wir wenn wir von langfristiger
Nachhaltigkeit und dem Wohl unseres
Lebens und das unserer Kinder sprechen
auch uns verändern
müssen
[Musik]
das ist der Beginn einer kehtwendee und
zwar nicht nur um Mode auf
verantwortungsvollere Weise zu machen
sondern um die Formen des Kapitalismus
und die des Wirtschaftens zu erneuern
ich bin mir sicher dass wir eine
signifikante Veränderung in den
kommenden 10 Jahren erleben werden ob
sie noch rechtzeitig geschieht ist eine
andere
Frage Martin Luther King jor sagte mal
bei einer Predigt in Brooklyn dass was
Amerika bräuchte wäre eine Revolution
der Werte es müsse aufhören Menschen wie
Gegenstände zu behandeln und damit
aufhören Profite über die Menschen zu
stellen um stattdessen Menschen mit
diesen Profiten auf humane Weise zu
[Musik]
behandeln be Gott wir könnten es doch
viel besser lösen wenn wir wollen und
zwar wenn wir die Industrie wie ich es
immer fordere auf der Welt verteilen
würden anstatt sie an einem Zentrum zu
konzentrieren lass uns doch auch den
Nutzen globalisiert teilen und zwar auf
ordnungsgemäßer adäquater und
sorgfältiger
[Musik]
Weise wir müssen erkennen dass Kapital
nur Geld ist und Geld ein Zweckmittel
die Menschen sollten dafür
verantwortlich gemacht werden wie damit
umgegangen wird und wir müssen die
Schöpfungskraft der Menschen würdigen
undfangen
anstelle von
Arbeit wir dürfen Land nicht als eine
wre ansehen mit der spekuliert oder
gehandelt werden kann sondern als die
Lebensgrundlage von uns
ein wir müssen alle Verbraucher in
Aktivisten verwandeln die moralische
Fragen stellen und zwar ganz einfache
Fragen z.B über die Herkunft der
Kleidung sie müssen für sich sagen es
inakzeptabel ist wenn jemand an seinem
Arbeitsplatz sterben muss doch nicht
einfach machen lassen was sie wollen es
hat zu viele globale negative
Auswirkungen auf Millionen von Menschen
und auf gemeinsame
Rohstoffe werden wir weiterhin das Glück
im Konsum von Dingen suchen werden wir
uns weiterhin mit einem System zufrieden
geben das uns nur reich fühlen lässt
während wir diese Welt für unsere
Nachkommen Arm hinterlassen werden wir
weiterhin über Leben einfach hinwegsehen
die unsere Kleidung erst ermöglichen
oder wird dies ein Wendepunkt sein ein
neues Kapitel in unserer Geschichte in
dem wir gemeinsam eine wirkliche
Veränderung bewirken indem wir uns
bewusst machen dass alles was wir tragen
aus Menschenhand entstanden ist inmitten
all dieser Herausforderungen und all der
Probleme die uns vollkommen ohnmächtig
fühlen lassen könnten wir vielleicht
hiermit anfangen unserer
[Musik]
Kleidung
i
will
show
clean make
[Musik]
[Applaus]
i
[Musik]
make
ure Cap
[Musik]
[Applaus]
cap
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ه